[موسيقى]
ونرحب بكم ما في نقاش فرانس فتكات يمكنكم
كالعاده ان تتفاعل مع ما يقولوا ضيوف
البرنامج على صفحتنا على فيسبوك او على
صفحه البرنامج على تويتر
حتى بين الضيوف نقاشنا عن قمه العشرين
لنحاول ان نعرف ان كانت هذه القمه ستفلح
في انشاء جبهه كفيله بوقف الحرب في
اوكرانيا الخلافات قائمه بين دول الغربيه
تدين الغزو الروسي وتطالب بالمزيد من
الضغط ودول في الجنوب ودول صعده تدمر من
تداعيه هذه الحرب
الجنوبيه تتخبط في مواجهه رصاص من نوع اخر
هو الفقر ونقص الغذاء والتهاب الاسعار في
الاخير تم التوصل الى مشروع بيان مشترك
يقر بخطوره تداعيات هذه الحرب هل هذا يعني
ان اختلاف المقاربات قد يعطل عمليه البحث
عن فعلا لوقف الحرب الى اي حد توجد رغبه
لدى الجانبين المعنيين مباشره الروسي
ولوكراني لكي الصفحه وتبقا لاي شروط سعيد
بان يكون معي في الاستديو ولي الدين
المسعودي وهو باحث في الدراسات الجيوس
السياسيه سعيد بان يكون معنا من موسكو
اريكسوندرز سكين وهو دبلوماسي روسي سابق
وسيد بان يكون معنا من كياف يفهيين ميكينج
كو وهو مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاخرانيه
اهلا وسهلا بكم حتى نضعكم في الصحن مثل ما
يقول مثلا فرنسي نستمع الى ما قاله وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجيو راموس
مباراه
رغبته في متابعه التواصل مع الرئيس بوتين
كل المشاكل التي ترتبط بالجانب الاوكراني
الذي يرفض بشكل قاطع المفاوضات ويطرح شروط
من الواضح انها غير واقعيه ولا تتناسب مع
الوضع على الارض
[موسيقى]
فكرتم قضيه المناخ مثالا وهي من اكثر
الازمات ولكن هناك ايضا الازمات الدوليه
الاخرى الحرب التي شنتها روسيا في
اوكرانيا
الاندلسي الذي يستضيف هذه القمه
يجب ان نقسم العالم الى اجزاء يجب ان نترك
العالم يقع في حرب العالميه جديده
للحوار مع موسكو هل تعتقد ان هذه القمه
قمه العشرين لهل امكانيات للضغط على
الجانبين حتى يلتقي حول مائده حوار
مساء الخير
شكرا على استضافتي والله انا كنت مش متاكد
بدنا نحن نشوفكم اليوم ليش لان قبل اربع
ساعات قامت ضربه قاسيه من روسيا على
اوكرانيا
رقم قياسي
خلال ساعتين وصلتنا اسقطت
84 صاروخ روسي اليوم الرقم القياسي الجديد
100 صاروخ تم
اطلاقها الاوكرانيا ومنهم تقريبا 80 صاروخ
ولكن
كثير من الصواريخ ضربوا مدن اوكرانيه
مختلفه بما في ذلك كيف والليف يعني تقريبا
كله اكراد والان للاسف الشديد همم
نعيش في
قله كهرباء وقله تطفئه وقله مياه الى اخره
الى اخره ولكن الحمد لله حتى
مشيت اليوم شويه في المساء
الناس همم يتمشون في كيف ما كشفاته يعني
كده شايف كيف
ولكن ما فيش ولا هذا ولا اخو ولا حاجه همم
انا سعيد جدا باليوم وامبارح
الصوت اللي اوكراني كان مسموع في بالي
انا
رئيس الاوكراني عن عده شروط الذين
نتمشويات
اشاره الوحيد المهم جدا هاي
سياده راضي اوكرانيه الشرطه الثانيه
الاعتراف
حدود وكرانيه
بمترفه دوليه
فان شاء الله نحن نعبر عن استردادنا على
المباحثات ولكن في نفس الوقت
شفته شفته اليوم كيف والله شيماء
مستعد
لمحادثات وتضرب خلال عده ساعات 100 صاروخ
وصواريخ حديثه عن البيوت
هناك في روسيا الان وهم يعيشون كمان قله
صواريخ ولكن
يستخدمون الصواريخ احدث الصواريخ
منها اسمه حنجر كنجاوي يعني
صاروخ اللي بتروح ثلاثه مرات همم السلط
يعني كده يعني مش معقوله والصاروخ الثانيه
على فكره اسكندر يعني وهي موجوده حتى حتى
في اوروبا
يعني في الساعات الاخيره وحتى قبل الساعات
الاخيره سمعنا يعني تلميحات الى امكانيه
الدخول في مفاوضات خاصه للعديد من الدول
تطالب بوقف هذه الحرب طبعا جاءت هذه
الضربات في خلال الدقائق او خلال ال- خلال
الساعتين الماضيتين ربما يعني هذه من قبل
روسيا ولكن هل هناك بالفعل
نيه لوقف الحرب هل هناك نيه للتجاوب مع
هذه النداءات لوقف الحرب
هل تسمعني
طبعا طبعا
حول موضوع تفاوض
يعني
بسيطه
[موسيقى]
الاوساط الخبراء الروس
الله شكوك كثيره حول كل الاحاديث حول
التفاوض
حسب الراي الاغلبيه الخبراء
هو مطروخ من الجانبين من الجانب الروسي
ومن الجانب الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
هذا محاوله
لتجميد الوضع او
يعني
للتاجيل
[موسيقى]
تاجيل المعارك يعني
التعشيره للوضع
للحل همم
ولكن همم
ربما بعتبروا عن وراء هذا لمصلحه الجانب
الاوكراني وبدو الله
يوصل السلاح الجديد الى الجيش الاوكراني
وياسر التدريب للجنود الاوكرانيين في بعض
الدول الاوروبيه
الجزئيه لن تستقبل
هناك سلاح المتطور ربما سوف تعطي همم يعطي
الى الجبهه في المستقبل الكريم
[موسيقى]
الله سلاح النار توه همم يعني في ظروف
الشيطان هناك يكون اقل فعاليه ولكن انا ما
بعرف
الصحه لكل هذه التوقعات بس انا مقتنع انه
في ظروف في الوقت الراهن الله موضوع
الاستمرار المعارك هو اقوى من ايه احاديث
حول التفاوض
طيب الان امام المشهد صعب ضيفي هنا في
الاستديو يعني هناك محاولات بدات في قمه
العشرين جاءت هذه ضربات ربما غيرت
المعطيات لا ندري كانت تتغير المعطيات ام
لا ولكن هناك دول تطالب بوقف الحرب لانها
تاثرت
بتداعيات هذه الحرب اذا هناك
يريد التفاوض بشروط ولكن هناك شقيقه يقول
لابد من وقف
تداعيات هذه الحرب على الاخر
هو في الحقيقه ال ال ال المطالب الاثنين
يعني يتماشون مع بعض يعني وقف الحرب من
ناحيه وايقاف انعكاساتها وتبيعاتها على
العالم برمته يعني هما في الحقيقه
متوازيان يعني حتى حتى بالنسبه للتصعيد
اللي شفناه اليوم بخصوص الصواريخ هذه ال
100 صاروخ
القصف الروسي يعني يمكن ان نعتبره من
ناحيه كصعيد يعني ربما يبعد احتمال ايجاد
حل والجلوس على طويله المفاوضات ولكن في
تقديري همم ممكن انه هذه ايضا همم علامه
من علامات ربما اعداد ربما لا مفاوضات
قادمه لانه احيانا تكون هناك الرصاصه
الاخيره ربما او الضربه القويه بين ظفرين
لاعداد مفاوضات من اجل البدء في المفاوضات
في وضعيه قوه ربما خاصه على الميدان يعني
ربما هو من هنا قد افهم يعني تبقى فرض
طبعا انه الجانب الروسي ربما يصعد لاظهار
قوته اكثر على الميدان خصوصا بعد السيطره
على جانب مهم من الاراضي الاوكرانيه لي
امكانيه فيما بعد الدخول في مفاوضات وربما
التنقيس او التقليص نوعا ما من الشروط
التي وضعها الرئيس الاوكراني والتي
اعتبرها رئيس
عفوا وزير الخارجيه الروسي كاشروط تعجيزيه
يعني هذا اصلا حتى حتى هذه الشروط ربما قد
تبدو حتى موضوعيا يعني تعجيزيه ولكن في
النهايه مجرد الاستعداد همم للمفاوضات هو
همم يعني يبقى يبقى عنصر مهم وعنصر ايجابي
ربما هذه هي الشروط شروط بدء المفاوضات
وفيما بعد طبعا بالتفاوض ربما تكون هناك
تنازلات يعني من الطرفين بتدخل طبعا اطراف
اخرى دوليه واقليميه شفنا همم الدور
الفرنسي مانويل اه شفنا المفاوضات او
اللقاء بين همم الرئيس الامريكي
والرئيس الصيني هذه كلها بوادر انه هناك
حوار هناك رغبه في ايقاف الحرب هذا اكيد
يعني الانعكاسات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
كلها يعني نتحدث عنها منذ تسعه اشهر لكن
تبقى كيف سينتهي هذا الميزان همم سينتهي
اعتقد انه ينتهي يعني عاجلا عاجلا يجب وضع
حد لهذا لهذا الصراع ولكن كيف بوادر
الازمه خلال هذه القمه النقاشات المتواصله
والاستعداد للتفاوض في حد ذاته اعتبره
خطوه الى الامام يبقى البقيه يعني حسب
تطورات الاوضاع طيب هي فين همم
رايتك وكانك تريد تتجاوب مع الضيف في في
موسكو ولكن الان بدات بالفعل ديدات من قبل
دول صاعده الى ضروره وقف هذه الحرب لان
الدول الفقيره لم تع تتحمل هذه التداعيات
وبدا حتى من يشير بان الى متى ستدوم هذه
الحرب ولابد من وقتها لاننا سنواجه ازمه
غذاء نواجه ازمه طاقه نواجه ايضا الازمه
بيئيه اذا ما العمل عليه الا يوجد خوف ان
يتم تحميل المسؤوليه لجانب دون اخر
همم انا موافق معك نحن فاهمين جيدا جدا
بينا انا وسيدنا
ونحن جيران
حدود مشتركه بين روسيا واوكرانيا اكثر من
الف كلمه 1400 كيلو متر
وكانت معارك تدور هناك على مسافه الاقل
100 كيلو متر
فنحن مرهم جيدا بينا نحن اوكرانيا سنبقى
هنا في اراضينا
اوكرانيا بالقوه بدون دعوه بدون شيء اذا
واحد يجيك الى الى شقتك
هاي شقه تمام اوكرانيه ولكن هاي غرفه غرفه
همم يعني مناطق مناطق الاوكرانيه همم
بالروشه شو هذا
ونحن نعيش وين في قرن 21 لماذا ذلك وعلى
فكره في منطقه مثلا دونيتك مختلف ب 60%
فقط
95% ولكن محافظه غير شون
60% من مساحتها ومحافظه
زوال تعمل
الاكبر محطه قهر النوويه في اوروبا
سته مولدات كهرباء نوويه نحن لدينا اييه
يعني خبره سيئه جدا في زمان الاتحاد
السوفيتي
1986 لما انفجرت مولد في محطه شرنوبل هذه
كانت يعني
اوروبيه
بصوره شريفه مش نحن اللي بدانا هيك حرب مش
نحن اللي بدانا ازمه
ما فيش تقصد ماذا من يجب ان يتنازل لمن
فالمفاوضات تقصد اقصد في المفاوضات
نحن بدنا يعني
مقابل سلام انتم تعرفون اكثر مني هذه ما
ابدا ولكن لا نريد تكرار هاي حكايه
الارض للسلام
الى اوكرانيا نحن لا بدنا ولا شبر من
الارض من روسيا
ضيفه من موسكو الان التعويل على ماذا
التعويل على ملل دول بدات تعاني من تدعيه
حسب ما فهمت من قيمه العشرين دول بدات
تعاني من تداعيات هذه الحرب وبدات تتحدث
راحه وتسال الى متى ستدوم هذه الحرب لاننا
بسبب دفع الثمن ام ان الرهان على الدخول
ربما او اعطاء الامكانيه للصين مثلا ان
تلعب دور الوسيط لايجاد تسويه لهذه الازمه
يا سيدي انا اشكرك في فعاليه ايه وصاطا
او
مواقعيه
التي انا شخصيا انا لا ارى الان في ظروف
الراهنه الامكانيه الوصول الى القواسم
المشتركه لانه طبعا القصه تاريخ لهذه
العظمه قصه طويله وبنسبه لروسيا هذه القصه
تعود الى سنه 14 وبعد ذلك عبر المراحل
الاتفاقات
ووصول الى العمليه العسكريه التي تعتبر في
روسيا انه كانت روسيا مضطره
لاتخاصه الكرام
على كل حال في هذه الظروف
انه ربما
التعشيرات السلبيه لما يجري على الاقتصاد
الغربي ربما يشجع على التحرك الدول
الغربيه خاصه اوروبيه
واقل شويه الله امريكا
ربما ولكن ولكن في نفس الوقت انه اشاره
الى انه القرار الله همم يعود الى رئيس
اليونسكي الى الجانب الاوكراني
فلذلك يجب ان نرى بصوره واضحه اين هناك
مواقيه والمواق الفروسيه فهناك تناقض مع
بعض اثنين وفي ظروف الراهنه مثل اكرر انه
لا يوجط القاسم المشترك فهنا
الوساطه لن
تنفع همم لانه على اي اساس ما فيش الا
الله
اي شيء ممكن ان يقترح الجانب الثالث
يقف للجانب الاوكرانيوم
همم يعني همم العالم الغربيه يفهم الموقف
الاوكراني انه همم كما هو كما يعلن
الجانب والله خالص مثل الصين او شيء همم
لا يقف بالكامل همم او لا يعقوب في لجان
بروسيا يا اخي في لجان يبقى الحل السياسي
السلمي همم ولكن ضمن طبعا هناك تفاهم مع
روسيا ولو
بشؤون اخرى ولسه مثلا الازمه الاوكرانيه
بالاوضاع العالميه والقضايا الاعلاميه
الاساسيه و يقفل لنا همم ولكن فيما يخص
بالله مثلا تنقيه الاجوال العالميه همم
طبعا ولكن بنظبط للحلق اليوم ما بين روسي
واوكرانيا مفيش
لو اردناها
الاربعه مقطوعات اصبح حتى وفقا للدستوره
الروسي اصبح
الدوله الروسيه
ما هو الاساس للحديث عن هذا الشيء همم
رئيس بوتين قال منذ الفتره انه كل ما يمر
الوقت يكون اصعب اصعب على الوصول الى
الخلق
اجري طيب لا توجد قواسم مشتركه يقول الضيف
موسكو هذا اولا
ثانيا حتى في الحديث عندما يتحدث ماكرون
عن رئيس الصيني يطلب منه ان يضغط على
الجانب الروسي بالضبط هذا هو الشيء الذي
حاولت الذي جلب انتباهي من دخلت
ضيفك من من موسكو بخصوص انه صحيح هو في في
الواقعه هي مفاوضات ستكون يعني روسيه
اوكرانيه مباشره ربما الوسطات ستكون صعبه
فيها لكن لا يجب ان ننسى ان الصراع في
النهايه صحيح انه صراع روسي اوكراني هذا
اليوم لكن روسيا بالكتله التي خلفها
واوكرانيا بالكتله الاخرى التي خلفها يعني
بعد الاصطفاف هذا اللي وقع يعني منذ مده
وخاصه بالنسبه للجانب الروسي لان الروسي
قوه عظم ليوم صارت يعني تقوم بدور نوعا ما
منافس للدور الامريكي ربما وحتى الدور
الصيني يعني من حيث الحجم وقوه التاثير
والفاعليه
فروسيا يمكن ان تلعب الصين مثلا دورا
للضغط على روسيا من اجل ربما القيام
بتنازلات او من اجل جلوس على طويله
المفاوضات وخاصه فيما بعد من حيث التفاصيل
من جانب الاخر لنا اوكرانيا اوكرانيا صحيح
هي تخوض الحرب يعني والشعب الاوكراني هو
الذي يعاني يعني كل يوم في الع- على ارض
الميدان لكن في النهايه القوه الغربيه من
الجانب الاخر هي التي تدعم بطريقه اخرى
وبالتالي يمكن للقوه الغربيه بقياده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي شفنا حتى ماكرون يعني فرنسا يظهر
يعني الرغبه في لاعب دور مهم في فرض هذا
النزاه حتى للرمزيه التاريخيه ربما اصلا
فهذا مهم وبالتالي ممكن ان
تلعب الدول الغربيه قوه الضغط ودفع للجانب
الاوكراني ومن الجانب الاخر ربما الصين قد
تلعب دور مؤثر ودور يعني ضغط على روسيا من
اجل تقريب وجهه النظر خلينا نقوله لكن
فيما بعد لما ندخل في تفاصيل المفاوضات
وهذه الشروط التي قد تبدو تعجيزيه او لا
كما تفضل ضيفك من من روسيا وقال ان
الاراضي التي تم السيطره عليها هي اليوم
صار يعني اراضي روسيه من تحصيل الحاصل فهل
روسيا ستكون مستعده غدا بعد كل هذه
المجهودات بين ظفرين ان تتخلى عن كل هذا
ونرجع لوضعيه الصفر يعني هذا ما تطلبه
اوكرانيا اليوم وبالتالي لهذا الشيء قلت
في البدايه ان اوكرانيا من العادي ومن
الاساسي والطبيعي ان تبدا بوضع هذه الشروط
لانه حتى بالمعطيات يعني نظرا للقوانين
الدوليه وغيره فهذا معقول يعني ان تبدا
بهذا ولكن لا اعتق ان امكانيه حل الازمه
سيكون وارد اذا تم التشبث بصفه مطلقه
ونهائيه بيده شروط ولكن عادي المفاوضات هي
التي ستجعل فيما بعد ان هناك حلول اخرى
ستظهر
طيب يفهم
اريد ان نفهم منك يعني هل
برايك نتحدى شويه دبلوماسيه لا نبقى في
الثنائي الروسيه
الاوكراني باعتبار انك انت دبلوماسي
ومستشار وزير الخارجيه هناك دول
اراهانت على
تنازل روسي او تنازلات من قبل روسيا من
خلال دعم اوكرانيا بالسلاح ودعم اوكراني
بالمال وبكل الامكانيات اذن والان هناك
ادراك بان هذا الرهان له حدود
فهل تعتقد ان اوكرانيا كما روسيا على
استعداد للقيام ببعض المراجعات
جارنا الكبير وقوي والاخره
روسيا اكبر من اوكرانيا
28 مره
في عدد سكان اربع مرات
نحن نعترف بذلك ولكن نحن كمان نعترف بان
روسيا لن تروح الى الى مريخ على سبيل
المثال او القمر ستبقى روسيا روسيا ولكن
من البديهي شيء عجيب يعني كيف روسيا من
مؤسسين همم مجلس الامن
المتحده
واكثر من 120 دره 140
143 دوله
تستنكر في تصويت تستنكر الغزو الروسي فقط
خمس دول
كانوا ماروسك الحلوه هذه دول معروفه كوريا
شو هذا
اغلبيه الساحقه
لدول الاجنبيه
يعترفون بنهايكان
عدوان نحن مجتهدين تمام خلينا نيجي ولكن
بدون ابتزاز بدون انذار انذارات وبدون قوه
نحن لا نريد ولا شيء بس عداله
اوكي لكن هل تعتقد مثلا ان قمه العشرين
يمكن ان تفرز
مسارا على الاقل يقرب وجهات النظر ام ان
الامور تبدو صعبه جدا حينما توجد خلافات
حتى داخل قمه العشرين خلافات في المقاربه
كيف نتعاطى مع هذا الموضوع
انا حسسته يمكن انا خاطئ ولكن انا
حساسته
بان قمه 20 في بالي كانزه
الحقيقه
للصين
من زمان ماهو الدور الصين في العالم اليوم
دور كبير جدا ضخم فانا عندي شعور بيننا
ستطور الامور وستتطور في اتجاه العداله
العداله
اليكساندر ذا سكين اريد منك ان تعيضا لان
الرساله التي تصل الان من قمه العشرين
خاصه على لسان
الرؤساء الدول الغربيه هل يمكن لها ان تصل
الى بوتين وكيف يمكن لهون يتفاعل معها
خاصه من الامور تتعلق الان
باتجاه او تسير باتجاه المزيد من الضغط
على موسكو
المجموع طلع 20 افضل من مجموعه سبعه
ما حصل مثلا الان انه تاكيد على الانقسام
هناك الانقسام في المجتمع دولي هناك
الانقسام في مجموعه العشرين طيب صحيح انه
الامريكان عنده نفوز
كبير جدا في كل المؤسسات الدوليه يمكن
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده
وهو موجود
حتى الان هذا هو الاساس بالنسبه
لروسيه بغض النظر عن المواقف في عدد همم
الدول التي تصوب كازا او كذا ولا احنا
نعرف والمطبخ همم الاميه وكذلك في مجموعه
العشرين هناك جزء همم الكبير همم
السياسه الامريكيه همم
وفقا للمصادر
بيعتبروا المصلحه
الامريكا وفي هناك دول اخرى والصين والعين
همم
افريقيا الجنوبيه وهمم ربهم السعوديه همم
بدنا درجات
خروج عديده فلذلك عندما نتحدث في القرن 21
او 20 او شيء ويجب ان نتذكر انه على كل
الاعمار الامريكيه في همم في الشرق الاوسط
مثلا او في اوروبا
همم طيب بالتالي
مين قمه العشرين ان يكون فعلا همم دور همم
دور فعال في في هذا في هذا الخصوص العظمه
في حوله
همم شيء
اه صحيح هناك ترابط مع بوينا ولا حوله
اوكرانيا والوضع الدولي همم
ولكن هناك كذلك في نقطه مهمه انه ليس كل
الاصامات الان نابعه من الازمه في
اوكرانيا لانه هناك خطر
على هناك
قبل عمليه
الروسيه في في اوكرانيا او ااه
حتى الطاقه الموضوع هذا مطروح من زمان من
الجانب الاوروبي وبدون لعبه حول الموضوع
خلال مده طويله في في كل الاحوال لانه
اولها انه عيسى كان هناك تنقيط الاجواء
الدوليه همم بمعنى
ياخذ يعني الاعتبار ال ال مخاوف الروسيه
تتعلق بالامن الروسي لانه هناك خطه
الامريكيه طويله عريضه بالنسبه الله تقرب
من الاراضي الروسيه
لتشغيل الصواريخ الجديده من الجيل الجديد
الحديث خلال سنوات القادمه
[موسيقى]
معزوم همم
يعني انا اشعر ال- ال- المناخل مش
لمصلحه تنازلات الرئيس قالوا لل- عنود في
تنازلات ان يكون مرفوض ولا احنا نعرف انه
هناك على قوى في في اوكرانيا طبعا اذا
قالوا لهم همم
تراجع فيكون
هذا
في روسيا انه بيقولوا صار فيه مخالفه
للدكتور مثلا الله اربع مناطق يعني فيكون
مرفوض
فهذا هو المعظم
بصراحه في في رايي يعني
قمه العشرين هو الجانب المهم انه اعتقد
انه تم الاستثمار في قمه العشرين من اجل
ربما طرح امكانيه لفضل نزال
الماليه العالميه لكن تم استغلالها وفي
راي حتى لو لم تكن هناك قمه العشرين ربما
لقد وجدنا نفسنا في نفس الوضعيه اليوم
للتحدث عن ربما مفاوضات لكنها كانت سياق
جيد لي طرح الموضوع خصوصا في حضور الصين
يعني همم لينكون واضحين يعني
في الحقيقه همم نوع من سحب البساط او من
سحب ربما نوع من المشروعيه على اي قرار او
اي موقف يخرج من قمه العشق
كوزير خارجيه ولكن يغادر وياتي وزير
الماليه على اساس ان الرساله هذه قمه
اقتصاديه
وتتحدثوره ربما او المشاركه من اجل
المشاركه لعدم المخاطره يعني ربما بمفاجاه
غير ساره بالنسبه لجانب الروسي يبقى
بالنسبه للمواقف الدوليه يعني مثلا اليوم
لما نقول انه همم هناك تفكك في وجهات
النظر بين الدول والانقسام في النهايه ليس
هناك اصطفاف بهذا الحجم الذي ربما اليوم
يعني في النهايه كما كما قال ضيفك من من
كيف 143 دوله يعني متفقين واذان وهذا هذا
هذا هذا هذا هذه العمليه كما يقول الروس
وهذه الحرب يعني في النهايه خمسه دول فقط
هي التي تساند روسيا رسميا وهي الدول
المغضوب عليهم يعني نوعا ما على المستوى
الدولي والاقيمي الى اخره يعني
بقيه الدول التي لم تتخذ موقفا واضحا
وصريحا للادانه لادانه هذه الحرب هي
الاطراف التي لا تريد المجابه والمخاطره
والمقاومره لان ربما غدا روسيا قد تقلب
موازين القوى وقد تتبعثر الاوراق من جديد
وربما سيضر بهذا ذلك فهذا في النهايه
الموقف الموحد للادانه الحرب موجود
والمشروعيه موجوده بالنسبه للقوه الغربيه
وحلفائها والاطراف الاخرى التي تساندها
لكن الاراده السياسيه كما قلنا وخاصه
الجاهزيه الاخرانيه الروسيه رسميا
للمفاوضات هي الخطوه التي كانت ناقصه
واليوم في النهايه حتى وان تبدوا
المفاوضات صعبه مجرد الاعلان عن الاستعداد
للتفاوض في راي خطوه ايجابيه اتت بها قمه
العشرين ربما لمجرد السياق ولكن الاهم هو
حضور الصين في هذه القمل طيب همم ميجا
تنقل الان بدات التساؤلات عن مرحله ما بعد
هذه الحرب
وهناك وقرات حتى مقالات تتسال طيب
اوكرانيا ستحتاج الى اكثر من 1000 مليار
يورو لاعاده البناء ربما تزداد الخلافات
عندما يطرح موضوع تقاسم هذه المباله من
سيدفع ومن لا سيدفع هناك دول ستقول نحن لم
ندخل في هذه الحرب انتم طولتم هذه الحرب
من الجانبين وبالتالي عليكم تحمل مسؤوليه
نحن لا يمكننا نتحمل هذه المسؤوليه هذا
الاشكال مطروح هذا التساؤلات موجوده في
اوكرانيا
باند من بنود
من اوكرانيا من
الجاهزيه للمفاوضات فيما في ذلك
تعويذات من العدو
التعويضات على اوكرانيا
يعني ارقام تتغير ولكن انتم بعيدين
وانتم لا تتصورون ماذا يحدث
في اوروبا الغربيه
عايشين داخل اوكرانيا ولكن في الغرب
الاخيره
امي المتحده
كمان ولكن نحن صدرنا منذ شهرين تقريبا 12
مليون تون من منتجات زراعيه من تسنيم
قمح والشعير وزيت بعض الشمس والاخر بدايه
عن استلام او شراء
المنتجات زرعيه من اوكرانيا لماذا لا نحن
مجتهدين ولكن طبعا انا اذكركم كان في واحد
وزير خارجيه في الاتحاد السوفيتي هو من
جورجيا سيد ادبر
دبلوماسي يعني شاب في سفاره في بغداد وهو
كان يزور بغداد الحرب الايرانيه
وانا شربته في المباحثات كمترجم على فكره
فانا اتذكر عندما كان يتحدث دائما
واحده من مفاوضات احسن من يوم واحد من
الحرب انا بعرف شو هذا الحرب
وانت اشتغلته 10 سنوات في لبنان صحيح ام
لا انت بتعرفونا ماذا يعني لبنان
مساحه التي احتلال الروسي
تعادل الى حد ما تعادل مساحتها الامارات
المتحده صوروا
فانا ارجو منك خلينا نتذكر السيد في
برنامج زين
يوم واحد من الحرب اسوا من
63 يوم من المفاوضات
هل ترد عليه فيما يتعلق الدبلوماسيه طبعا
مساء الخير
النظام الايراني الجديده
[موسيقى]
سلام افضل بكثير همم
مين الحرب وتفاوته احسن من الخرق همم
هذا مضبوط ومعنى همم الى حلول همم
السياسيه والله ما ما يجري همم
الان همم ابدا ليش يصنع مسرورين على
الاطلاق بالعكس انه هذا همم
نحن نرفض ذلك اليوم نفوسنا لانه همم فعل
هذا
حرفه بين الاشقاء الام بيقولوا شعب واحد
او يكون شعب روسي وشعبه بكره يعني انا انا
لا اريد ان اشير الى ما هو الاخصنا همم
الموقف يكون شعب واحد او اثنين همم
انا هاخترم الشع يلا
وصلنا وشعب وقراني شعب همم
ممتاز وعندي ذكريات لزيارته اوكراني ويكون
على كل حال همم
يجب الجاط
الخال وما انا قلت اليوم انه ما فيش ناقه
القواسم المشتركه هذا اعتراف بهذه الحقيقه
بهذا امر الواحد كيف ممكن التجاوز على هذا
ال- همم على هذا الوضع هذا هو سؤال
المطروح الان امام امام
الجميع همم ويجب ان نكون واقعيين وبدون
اوهام همم
دور للمجتمع دول ممكن يكون مهم وممكن يكون
همم مفيد فعال ودور صيني ولكن ايضا يجب ان
اعترف عنه الايديولوجيه على الغربيه هي هي
الهيمنه وهذا مرفوض من الجانب الروسي ويجب
ان يكون مضمومه
المجتمع الراي العام في روسيا بعتبر عن
روسيه هي في لاعب الدول التي ترفض الهامه
الغربيه القياده الامريكيه هذا هو القصاص
لما يجري بمفهوم الروسي
لما تحدثنا عن الهيمنه والايديولوجيا بدات
تظهر يعني ربما الاسباب الحقيقيه والفعليه
لهذه الحرب يعني كلنا كلنا متفقون يعني
وحتى ضيوفك متفقين رغم انهم الاحد روسي
والاخر اوكراني يعني تشتغلوا في مجالات
حساسه من الدوله وكذا ومتفقين يعني انه
الحل دائما السلم افضل والمفاوضات افضل من
الحرب لكن في النهايه الخلاف الايديولوجي
والخلاف التصور حتى النظام ربما النظام
العالمي كيفيه تنظيم العلاقات في الدوليه
في العالم
ده سبب الحرب يعني في الاساس فهل اليوم
روسيا مستعده للرجوع الى الوراء من اجل
همم السلم هل السلم اليوم جيو سياسيا يعني
وبمنطق المصلحه والتاريخ وغيره هل اليوم
مستعدون او فما امكانيه للرجوع الى الوراء
يعني هذا في رايي هذا الموضوع نقاب هذا
الموضوع نقاش هذا الشكر في الختام لوالديه
المسعودي باحث في الدراسات الجنسيه
السياسيه والشكر لله
في همم
مستشار وزير الخارجيه شكرا لفريق البرنامج
حمصيه مريحه الجميع